ich frage mich in diesen wochen können
praktikanten und mitarbeiter sehr
unfreundlich bedrohen ein oder schreien
einen an würde hier nicht hingehen
manche haben sogar messer mit denen
allein erstmal schreiben sie mich und
freunde bedroht haben
[Musik]
hey was geht ab und herz willkommen bei
einem neuen video
ich hoffe natürlich euch geht's gut
leute heute mit einem video auf dass ich
wirklich sehr sehr gespannt bin was
passieren wird wir haben gerade abends
ihr könnt es schon sehen draußen ist es
dunkel und ich möchte morgen früh nach
ist glaube ich gar nicht mehr köln ist
er schon leverkusen also für die diese
interessierten den genauen ort muss ich
ja gar nicht sagen dann auf jeden fall
geht es morgen zu einem supermarkt ich
habe irgendwann mal unter meinen letzten
videos gelesen ja alex frei schoss
hinaus zu was jetzt in so vielen
schlechten restaurants blabla geht auch
mal eine schlechtesten supermarkt da
habe ich gedacht eigentlich eine geile
idee mag okay bob was findet weil ja ich
hab mir das jetzt nicht so leicht
vorgestellt um ehrlich zu sein in ganz
köln gibt es auch nur diese typischen
supermarktketten wie man sie erkennt und
die waren alle mindestens mit 3,2
sternen bewertet ungefähr also nichts
auffälliges dann bin ich auf die idee
gekommen was auf leverkusens um die ecke
schaut doch einfach mal nach und zeigt
bin ich sofort auf einem shop gestoßen
ich habe keine ahnung was da gibt war
doch mal steht das hier vielleicht
irgendwie auch meine das ist und ich
lese mir die rezension dann natürlich ja
selber schon mal durch und bei diesen
rezensionen dachte mir wirklich what the
[ __ ]
also ja das gut ausgedrückt also da gibt
es wohl alles mögliche wir haben so
gartenartikel wir haben aber auch
lebensmittel kann ich euch hier nochmal
zeigen also sieht das ungefähr aus leute
und jetzt haltet euch fest
jetzt kommen nämlich die rezension hier
würde ich mal sagen eine relativ normale
teilweise das niveau eines rahmen
schlagens wenig übersichtlich wirkt wie
wahllos hingestellt und fertig das wäre
so eine rezension will ich sagen okay
wenn du dass du siehst deine meinung das
ergibt mir ist kein anreiz zu überprüfen
ob das jetzt wirklich so ist weil da hat
jeder seine eigene meinung auch dieser
kommentar hier keine ahnung tina alles
schon gut so und dann bin ich auf diese
kommentare gestoßen
und da dachte ich mir das ist jetzt
einfach mal vor so wie es da steht alles
iwe türkische praktikanten wollten uns
schlagen weil das kaufen wollten denke
ich mir schon so wenn du weißt dass
türken waren vielleicht war es ja auch
so was mache ich irgendwie gar nicht
wenn man so herabwürdigen so die
herkunft da direkt rein schreibt also
ich hab selber sehr viele türkische
deswegen gut aber diese kommentare gehen
weiter sehr unfreundliche praktikanten
haben uns geschlagen und das handy
entwendet werden in diesem augenblick
die polizei alarmieren
dabei erstmal eine google rezension
schreiben ganz wichtig praktikanten und
mitarbeiter sehr unfreundlich bedrohen
ein oder schreien einen an würde hier
nicht hingehen manche haben sogar messer
mit denen lerne erstmal schreiben sie
mich und freunde bedroht haben also wenn
man sich jetzt diese rezension hierdurch
liest als außenstehender
da wird man ja nicht einkaufen gehen
also das ist ja wirklich extrem ruf
schädigen mein gedanke ist allerdings
ich meine schaut mal hier auf den monat
alles vor fünf monaten alles auch so
komische gamern namen oder so so als
wenn ihr zusammen irgendwie league of
legends gerade gespielt habe nix funkie
drake pvp was weiß ich ich weiß nicht
was euch dieser laden getan hat
vielleicht ist es ja auch so gewesen
keine ahnung das willicher herausfinden
aber warum man dann solche rezensionen
verfasst und dann noch gegenseitig hier
die kommentare der anderen like wird
seinem account für mich schon krass
also es gibt sofort richtig los mit dem
video eine sache finde ich auch noch
lustig und zwar kann man hier bei google
werden immer so fragen eingetragen die
häufigsten gestellten fragen
und dann haben wir hier die frage sind
die praktikanten freundlich antwort nein
sogar sogar sehr unfreundlich die metro
nein sogar ich meine wer möchte dann
bitte wissen auch die praktikanten in
einem laden freundlich sind keiner oder
das schließt ja schon darauf hin das ist
absoluter quatsch es was dort steht ja
leute aber das finden wir heraus ich
würde sagen ich wünsche euch viel spaß
mit dem video das gern doch nach oben da
jack ma lin ceo ab 30 alex wie folgt da
sehr gerne und jaletzke deutsche
angekommen hier in leverkusen oder
zumindest also ich muß ich zumindest
durch leverkusen durchfahren
sagen wir es mal so war ich auch nicht
schön war zu sehen es ist so heftigem
regen ich möchte hier ein parkhaus
gefahren und jetzt bin ich mal gespannt
irgendwo hier in der nähe solcher laden
sein
deswegen ist es mal wieder schnell aufs
handy und dann bin ich mal gespannt was
mich da erwartet
bis gleich
so leute ich bin jetzt irgendwo im haus
keine ahnung ist auf jeden fall extrem
kalt hier irgendwie ein bisschen komisch
irgendwie alles so leute ich habe den
laden gefunden hier
ok jetzt bin ich mal gespannt
[Musik]
also ist auf jeden fall schon mal ein
riesenmarkt hätte ich gar nicht gedacht
[Musik]
also geben auf jeden fall viel in diese
stämme kann nicht ausgebrochen weil sie
nämlich mal mit 99 cent jetzt aber ich
mal irgend eine mitarbeiterin aber
mitarbeiter am besten oder praktikanten
ich frage mal ob ich ein praktikum
machen kann man das gute entschuldigung
praktikum machen kann im land lange so
zwei wochen von meiner ausbildung
ok viele waren wäre das denn was weiß
ich noch nicht wohl einfach immer noch
von hier haben wir haben aus ihr die
kommen ja ja wir haben praktikanten hier
auch heute durch immer okay ja sogar
dann weiß ich bescheid sagen schön
einfach per internet hallo so wieder
draußen eher leute also
war halt irgendwie ein ganz normaler
supermarkt so ich hatte jetzt auch etwas
spektakuläreres er hofft trotzdem muss
ich mal sagen also so von diesem ganzen
einkaufslagen hier oder auch mal das ist
irgendwie total leer und keine ahnung
also schon ein bisschen komisch jetzt
geht es hier wieder 20 meter und werden
dieses parkhaus ich habe diese beiden
sachen freundlicherweise mitgenommen
waren relativ kurzer besuch so leute da
bin ich schon wieder wie schon gesagt
waren relativ kurzer besuch überhaupt
mal gefragt ob man dann ein praktikum
machen kann
ich hatte auch mal fragen sollen das
fällt mir jetzt gerade jetzt auf warum
denn im internet irgendwas von ihrer
komischen praktikanten steht und
messerattacken oder so aber ich hab mir
gedacht da hoffen wir gleich auf jeden
fall noch mal an und fragen nach
das können ja so nicht sein und würde
mich auch mal interessieren euch ja
wahrscheinlich auch also jetzt geht's
erst mal nach hause und dann sich hier
gleich noch das gespräch ansonsten was
das eigentlich mit dem video und ich
hoffe es hat euch gefallen mal schauen
ob ich mich dafür ein praktikum bewerben
oder halt auch nicht
leute also wir haben ja schon den
nächsten tag ich rufe noch mal schnell
bei den supermarkt an und frage einfach
mal wie dann wohl diese bewertung
zustande kommen ob das wirklich mal so
gar keine ahnung was ich nicht glaube
vielleicht sagen die dazu ja auch gar
nichts ja probieren was machen
[Musik]
und zwar hätte ich meine frage ich
schreibe meine arbeit fürs studium über
rezension im internet und ich bin da auf
ihren supermarkt gestoßen und im
internet hat er total viele schlechte
bewertungen
ich habe jetzt allerdings von aus
erfahrung mitbekommen dass das manchmal
auch nicht so stimmt allerdings wollte
ich einfach mal nachfragen vielleicht
wollen sie dazu ja auch keine aus dem
film wissen sie überhaupt dass sie da so
schlecht bewertet dann im internet
also ich habe da nur irgendwas gehören
lesen von blöden praktikanten oder so da
habe ich mir schon gedacht das ist nicht
der wahrheit entspricht
[Musik]
okay aber trotzdem sind ja
wahrscheinlich diese schlechten
bewertungen entsprechend halt nicht der
wahrheit also das steht irgendwas von
einem messer übergriff oder so
aber wie gesagt auch mal mit mitarbeiter
probleme die auch der sache rein
geschrieben hast du ja gut finden was
ich mache das denn möchte der täter
etwas sagt dann keine reguläre
vorbeizukommen das finde ich persönlich
war bisschen schade ja das geht nicht
haben sie dass er nicht versucht oder so
weil das ist wenn das nicht der wahrheit
entspricht kann man dagegen glaubt also
soweit ich weiß kann man dagegen
vorgehen
das ist jetzt nicht der richtige ist sie
auch nachweisen dass ein berechtigtes
interesse ist das klagen ja also ich bin
jetzt überrascht dass sie so aus
österreich waren also auf jeden fall
vielen dank ja dann würde ich ihnen noch
einen schönen tag
vielen dank für die auskunft dankeschön
ok passt also der hat auf jeden fall mir
einiges erzählt ja ich weiß nicht ob ich
alles mit rein schneide aber hat halt
gesagt dass er davon auch weiß und dass
er glaubt dass das zustandekommen durch
einen ehemaligen mitarbeiter oder so
vielleicht keine ahnung dass sie aber
schon auch mal jemanden dort hatten der
gar nicht gepasst hat also keine ahnung
ich hatte ihm am ende auch noch sagen
kann das ist eigentlich für youtube
verbindet denke mal das wäre auch nicht
so schlimm gewesen aber gut so ist das
und das war's mit dem video das man
gerne doch nach oben da deswegen ganz
wichtig glaubt nicht mal alles was da
steht manchmal ist auch kompletter
blödsinn wie jetzt in diesem beispiel
haut rein